au relais au quai de loire premier
marché après la fin annoncée des sacs
plastique chez ce producteur de fruits
et légumes bio
pas de problème ça fait longtemps qu ici
on a le souci des natures le but c'est
d'avoir quelque chose de respectueux de
l'environnement on est en sont
conscients en agriculture biologique et
dans l'esprit ben on en utilise au
maximum le sac papier le recyclage c'est
à dire qu'on a du sac plastique mais que
les clients nous ramène ou qu'on
réutilise et on a des clients formidable
parce que les clients aussi nous
ramènent leurs sacs papier donc on évite
le gâchis au maximum un peu plus loin
voici le marchand de fruits secs et de
livres saumur pour les fruits secs
l'alternative en plastique est simple
mais comment faire avec les envies là
est le problème parce qu'à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on a des sacs fassi qui
commence à être biodégradable
donc qu'est ce que est ce que le bio des
gravasses brasseur en petits sachets
j'espère parce que sinon on va être
vraiment pénalisé au niveau à
parce que c'est vrai que les gens
viennent à qui est beaucoup mais on a
des pelles standard donc après pour
mettre dans les beaucoup ça prend un
temps fou parce que il faut déjà les
tares et les lis beaucoup et c'est donc
ça prend du temps après pour la vente
c'est vrai que ça pose problème pour
certaines corporations et la corporation
des poissonniers il est devenu tellement
évident même pour les plus écologistes
des consommateurs de transporter son
poisson dans un emballage étanche le sac
plastique
et pourtant quand j'ai commencé il ya
plus de 45 ans on vend des jo le poisson
l'enveloppé date j'attendais papier
kraft
voilà on utilisait beaucoup de papier
papier c'est quand même mais voilà c'est
vrai que les sacs sont venus après il y
en a beaucoup trop vous seriez prête
vous à retourner au papier kraft oui
bien sûr il le faut pour la planète
on a intérêt pour me please enfants et
il le faut
voilà ça fait plusieurs années qu'on en
parle
on va voir les pieds dedans il il le
faut les pieds dedans c'est déjà
largement le cas pour ceux qui vivent de
l'océan 122 millions de sacs plastiques
échouent chaque année sur les seules
côtes françaises
sans compter ceux qui auront été
absorbée dans l'ensemble de la chaîne
alimentaire pour finir par se retrouver
sur nos étals avec thor polluants
chimiques